so the term customer success obviously
sounds like what it is
it's making sure your customer is
successful but i think at least when i
was starting out as a founder
i didn't think too much about it and i
didn't really focus on it enough and
that's one of the things that i want to
talk about throughout this presence so
when you look at the customer life cycle
of when
a customer finds you to when they
actually onboard and expand
it breaks up into four main categories
so first a customer finds you
and it's the interest phase it's they
just learn about you they typically
learn about you through
some form of marketing that you're
putting out and that's how they
learn that they actually are interested
in possibly learning more about your
service
then they move into the the purchase or
decision phase which is when your sales
team comes in
and helps them convert so if you're on
the b2b side you probably have a robust
sales team
especially if you hire a ticket item
that will help them close the sale
if you're more of a low ticket sas this
purchase decision phase may be a lower
touch sales process but it still is that
sales and decision process
as well um same with the b2c and then
once they actually transition
to becoming customer they get moved into
onboarding onto your
and then eventually either renewing
their contract with you
expanding their contract or purchasing
again and being a repeat buyer and
that's
whole last section from onboarding to
renewal and expansion
is where customer success comes in and
where your customer success team lives
which so when you look at this full life
cycle of your customer success is
the entire time that the customers and
the most important time they're with you
is during this customer success phase
but i find that a lot of brands
including ourselves starting out focused
a ton on sales and not enough on
customer success
when really customer success is where
you have the most opportunity to really
scale your brand and make sure your
product market fit so
that kind of feeds into this statistic
here the probability of selling an
existing customer
is sixty to seventy percent and the
probability of selling a new prospect
is only five to twenty percent and i
point this out because
once again if you're focusing all of
your efforts or let's say even 90
of your efforts just on the new sales
and you're not focusing on customer
success which is the
major portion of your customer's life
cycle then you're missing out on this
low-hanging fruit
that has a probability of expanding
renewing
closing growing that's 60 to 70 so
significantly higher so three times is
likely
getting into that i'm going to talk
about this customer success mindset
and what we implemented on our team
starting out at statosphere
we had two customer success teams for
both our members
and our consumers and for our brand side
but we
called the brand side account managers
at first and then i quickly realized
that
they weren't account managers they were
so much more than that they were
customer success managers they were
making sure that the customer was being
successful we had to make sure that they
were approaching problems that way
and i found that by calling them account
managers they weren't approaching
problems the way that
i wanted them to approach them so for
example
some major points of the customer
success mindset are here so
first they prioritize customers needs
and goals over everything else
which means they'll actually prioritize
and we tell our customers
success team to prioritize customers
needs and goals over even
don't make sure they're using all the
parts of the product if they don't need
all the parts of the product make sure
that you're really listening to what
their goal is
and giving them the solution whether
that's through something stratosphere
can
provide or not and really looking at it
in a holistic just to make sure that
you're not
missing out especially as a startup when
you're your product may not be fully
built out
you don't want to just get in the habit
of your customer success team just
trying to hammer
the solution you have at your customer
when they might be asking for something
else and your customer success team is
just not listening so that's also a
great way where you can find
insights as well as you're growing out
your product so prioritizing those
customers needs and goals
over everything else being solution
focused so when
a customer comes to you with a problem
moping and having a positive attitude
and saying how do we solve this which
seems obvious
but really making sure that your
customer success team approaches
everything in a solution
focused manner really does change
overall
how customers interact with you and
realize that which is my next point that
they're the customer's advocate
we call our csm team the bff of our
customers we tell them no matter what
tell the customer that like
your goal is to make this successful for
them it helps defuse situations when
there is an issue when there was
mismatched expectations or something
make sure to let them know i'm on your
side and i want to figure out how to fix
this
and instantly diffuses the situation but
then it also gives you
opportunities to build those
relationships and expand with that
customer over time
next is being customer focused versus
product to feature focus which i talked
about a little bit
but i find with a lot of startups and
just companies in general you'll do a
sales call you'll get on-boarded and
you'll find that the the customer
success or the account manager is really
trying to get you to use a part of the
product you don't even want to use
and they're not even like listening to
your problem and giving you a solution
for it
so really finding out what is the
overall
customer situation and how can you best
approach a solution for them
that's not just solely focused on the
product that
you're selling and then lastly be
proactive versus reactive which i think
is one of the best ways to win over
clients
in the future and as a startup when you
are launching brand new products and
there are little bugs and little things
going wrong
it's great to be the one who messages
them first about it and it really just
also shows that that you're on top of
things as well so going into how to
shift this customer success mindset
this is an example of how our account
managers at the time used to approach
things they would say
my job is to make sure that our customer
fills out their portal on time
versus with a customer success mindset
my job is to make sure this campaign
is successful is as successful as
possible which
includes making sure they fill out their
campaign portal on time
so it goes from being this like checking
a box making sure they do things
to saying no let's explain why we're
asking them to check this box just
shifting that
in your verbiage and your messaging that
your team uses with
your customers whether it's b2c or b2b
really will change the way
that you learn what what your customer's
issues are and just how you
solve the different problems that you
have
okay it's time for another r crowd deal
of the week right now you can join our
crowd's investment in
moodify according to the deal memo
modify is radically altering the
multi-billion dollar fragrance market by
digitizing
sense moodify is the first company to
develop software that enables
function specific sense that according
to the deal memo
improve mental performance eliminate the
perception of bad odors and much
more you can get in early on moodify and
other unique opportunities at
ourcrowd.com
twist by the way did you know that our
crowd investors were able to get in on
some of the best ipos of 2019 and 2020
while they benefited from companies
ipointing like beyond meat and lemonade
and some of our crowds companies
have been acquired by buyers like intel
nike microsoft oracle
and uber with our crowd accredited
investors can invest directly and easily
in startups early before they ipo or get
bought
accredited investors can participate in
single company deals for as little as
ten thousand dollars or one of our
crowds funds for as little as fifty
thousand dollars again the our crowd
account is free just go to
rcrow.com twist o-u-r-c-r-o-w-d
dot com slash twist